et maintenant la fille d'ingrid bergman
interview la fille de roberto rossellini
tant sur nos réseaux pour bella
et
[Musique]
à la maison quand j'étais petit utilisa
beaucoup misent maintenant sur twitter
quelle est la question qu'on se pose le
plus souvent je crois c'est une
affirmation et me disent tu ressembles à
ta mère mais moi je me sens toujours que
je obligé de répondre je ne sais jamais
quoi dire
évidemment ça ma mère théorie aussi dans
le mode elinga en âge quand les autres
s'arrêtent
est-ce que tu as peur de vieillir mais
j'ai peur ne pas tellement peur quand il
sera plus agitées de faire aller lifting
à ça je ne sais pas parce que je me dis
toujours j'en ferai pas je vais c'est
parce que des fois quand on voit les
visages très naturel qu'ils n'ont pas
fait des liftings ils ont pas c'est
tellement beau on a commencé à voir la
vie on voit les gens voient même ce que
on va leur sentiment on voit tout c'est
tellement émouvant et puis des fois on
se dise où je ne sais pas si je
retrouvais quand tu serais très très
âgées
est ce que tu veux vraiment récluse
comme greta garbo marlene dietrich
non moi je ne crois pas moi je suis
italienne je ne pourrais jamais vivre en
reclus
moi j'ai besoin des gens de venir des
prisonniers de ma famille est ce que tu
crois que le film de martin scorsese
dont tu étais marié la dernière
tentation du christ et places publiques
non moi je suis sûr que c'est une
demande il est très religieux lui est un
homme très religieux à sa manière mais
moi je veux pas faire de la politique a
le droit de penser ce qu'ils veulent du
film aidé de la pensée des autres mais
moi je sais que marty les très religieux
sincèrement très religieux tout mairie
souvent non mais je me suis mariée de
voix je ne sais pas si ça fait ça fait
souvent je vais je vais me marier comme
ça je serais pas souvent et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'ina l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux